in this episode of the secret manager
video series
we'll talk about how secret manager
automatically versions
your secret payloads should you pin your
applications to a specific version
or always use latest stay tuned to find
out
[Music]
in secret manager a secret is a logical
collection of secret versions
versioning is a core tenant of reliable
systems
to support gradual rollout emergency
rollback
and auditing secret manager
automatically versions secret data
using secret versions and most
operations
like access destroy disable and enable
all take place on a secret version while
the parent secret holds metadata
information like
name and replication policy the secret
version stores the
actual secret payload your secret data
once a secret version is created its
payload is immutable
that means version 42 of a secret will
always contain the same payload
when a new secret version is added it
automatically becomes
the latest version so should your
applications pin to a specific version
or should they just use latest to answer
that question
i think we need to bring in an expert
hey rajna thanks for joining us today
thanks seth thank you for having me
so rajna is a software engineer who
works on google secret manager
okay rashna earlier i was telling our
viewers about
secret versioning and the latest alias
when should we pin our applications to a
specific version and
when would we use this latest alias sure
seth
to help answer that question let's look
at a hypothetical scenario
suppose we have an application that uses
an api key to communicate with a third
party service
if the application was using the latest
alias
secret manager would always return the
most recent value
regardless of whether that value was
ready to be consumed
if the application was pinned to a
specific version
secret manager would return the pinned
version even if a newer version exists
okay but then if i pin my application to
a specific secret version how would i
update the secret used by the
application do i have to package and
rebundle and redeploy my whole
application
actually yes at google we believe
secrets are configuration
and configuration should be versioned
with the deployable artifact
okay that kind of makes sense so that
way if there's a problem
or a bug i can easily roll back and
if i roll back my configuration would
include the old secret version so
my application is then bundled uh in a
known working version right
exactly okay okay
so it seems like the latest alias is not
good for production but it'd be really
useful when i'm doing
like rapid iteration like in my
development or staging environments is
that right
yes that's right seth awesome thanks
rajna
okay let's look at a google cloud
function that accesses a secret using
the secret manager api
while iterating in my local development
environment
i'd instruct my cloud function to access
the secret using the latest alias
but when i'm ready to move to production
i would pin
my deployment to a specific secret
version
secret manager's first class versioning
helps you follow a devops best practice
of reproducible deployments while the
latest alias provides a convenient
method for
rapidly iterating during development
that's all for this episode
in the next episode we'll talk about the
principle of least privilege and how
secret manager can help you get there
be sure to like subscribe and click the
bell to get notifications about new
episodes
for more tips and tricks with google
secret manager subscribe to google cloud
platform
you